boy there sure are a lot of cool movies
coming out in 2017 kind of makes you
just want this year to be over because
all we have left to look forward to is a
movie that stars Mads Mikkelsen is the
villain which is getting tons of
reshoots to make it less dark or wait
there's also that movie that stars Mads
Mikkelsen is a villain that's getting
reshoots to make it less dark you can
watch that one too but for the moment a
lot of cool stuff is in the process of
filming and it's always fun as a comic
fan to go look at the leaked set photos
and give your two cents on it because
we're never way off base with the
speculation first on the list is
something I'm sure you're all interested
in spider-man Winter Formal
I guess the implication here is that
spider-man notices a random civilian
helping the environment and also working
to be more physically active so in
response he throws him two stories into
the air to break those well-toned legs
of his then absconds with an illegally
procured bicycle while laughing
maniacally about how he actually was the
one who created Ultron an earlier set
photos we can also see Tom spider-man
hiding in an industrial pipe of some
sort this is clearly to conceal as
horribly baggy mask that he made himself
after losing the one Tony gave him and
if IMDB is to be believed this fine chap
here is actually nedley's aka the
Hobgoblin well the first Hobgoblin
before jack-o'-lantern becomes the
second Hobgoblin who then is possessed
by the demo goblin but this was all
after the fake Hobgoblin with the
deformed face but that was before Flash
Thompson pictured here was framed as the
Hobgoblin because he was stupid Ned's
wife except it was that famous fashion
designers evil twin brother all along
there's a [ __ ] airplane passing oh my
god it's pissing me off so much I want
to record and it's just y'all mic I
can't wait for his subplot to be adapted
as such well make for a very interesting
side villain alongside rumored
antagonists like shocker scorpion
vulture Norman Osborn Miles Morales and
a via red oh and zendaya might be Mary
Jane do with that what you will al King
Kara can we just dye her hair red yes
please maybe next up Thor Hard Rock Cafe
an adaptation of the famed comics story
planet ho
except Thor is there too I guess in this
video we see mark ruffalo wearing that
super dangerous toy that every kid in
2003 used to punch their cousin in the
nose I am really upset that this scene
leaked online because it basically
spoils the entire plot of the movie not
sure what point there isn't even seeing
it after the entire climax Flash
Thompson cameo and twist ending were
shown with the CGI stripped out
oh also Doctor Strange Marvel really
dropped the ball with this one someone
should be fired 12 percent oh that
reminds me the Justice League movie is
filming - ah here we go this is what we
really want you see the climax of this
film takes place inside of a Hollywood
costume department where Steppenwolf
creates a portal to apocalypse to bring
Darkseid through killing Zack Snyder
with an Omega beam who happen to be
shooting a movie in a soundstage next
door there's an entire subplot in the
film about how Zack portrayed by Flash
Thompson was afraid to shoot on
locations because the media would get
all kinds of set photos and footage of
everyone to make funny videos over so
instead he opted to film the whole thing
on a studio lot so there's nothing to
analyze and make jokes about 98%
guardians of the 80s logo - [ __ ]
nothing wait I just got word there's a
photo of Zoe Saldana as Gamora being
covered in ectoplasm due to this movie's
connection with the supernatural
elements of Doctor Strange yes that's
right Doctor Strange confirmed to be a
member of the guardians of the galaxy
alongside Flash Thompson and to close it
all up here we can see Benedict
Cumberbatch and unpronounceable walking
around but this later set photo depicts
the two Sorcerer's walking around and
the most recent images and video
confirmed that there will be mild scenes
of running and even jumping in the film
[ __ ] airplanes they're doing it again
God why do I record videos when it's the
air show Marvel's really outdoing
themselves with this one looks like we
have a full slate of interesting comic
movies coming up and I for one can't
wait to see the Flash Thompson unfold
over these next few months
alright I'll quit screwing around back
to Arkham Knight also holy [ __ ] it's
Deathstroke